في تطورات اخرى باقليم دومباس اعلنت سلطات
المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه الغاز عن مقتل
ثلاثه او 13 شخصا واصابه اكثر من خمسه
وعشرين في قصف الاوكرانيين في صواريخ هاي
مارس
وبالمدفع يستهدف مباني سكنيه في بلدتين
تابعتين للمقاطعه
فقالت السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان حصيله
قتل القذف الاوكراني ارتفع الى ثلاثه
اشخاص وفي المقابل اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه مقتل شخصين وجرح اخرين في قصف
روسيين استهدف مبنى سكنيا في مدينه
في الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها دمرت مستودعا للصواريخ والمدفعيه
تابعه للجيش الاوكراني في خاركيز وفي محطه
رادار للنظام الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات
300 في مقاطعه دونيت واضافت وزاره الدفاع
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اعترضت اربع
سيارات اوكرانيه وصاروخيه